[Music]  is she here yet  not yet mom no  then she's late  yes  she is late  [Music]  you're our highness  mommy  family are all gathered in the drawing  room  they are waiting  [Music]  three days  that's it  they're getting quite serious about you  so stand very still and smile a lot  they know everything  [Music]  they don't  mommy what happened to make you so sad  well yeah  there is no future past and the present  is the same thing  [Music]  diana they can't change you have to  change  you have to be able to do things you  hate you hate it has to be two of you is  the real one  and the one thing take pictures of it  for the good of the country  who's the country  [Music]  you are your own weapon  [Music]  will they kill me if you think  [Music]  you